micro brim and this isn't an
exaggeration every ecosystem on the
planet that keeps us alive and so I like
to point out to people that if animals
disappeared the microbial world wouldn't
even notice
whereas if microbes disappeared we would
die pretty much right away as those ice
sheets are retreating and those polar
bears are struggling the entire
microbial community around those melting
ices is changing and as that microbial
community is changing the whole way that
ecosystem function is changing and
that's what's really interesting polar
bears
we should save them and they're
important but actually the real
important science I would argue it's
happening in the sea around that
retreating ice front one of the things
that I work on specifically are a group
of microbes that make a greenhouse gas
called nitrous oxide and we know that
the concentration of that gas has been
increasing in the atmosphere and so
that's a direct example of where the
activity of microbes and the changes
that they're experiencing we can measure
that in their atmosphere so we can
measure the changes in the metabolism of
these microbes and the metabolism of
those microbes is going faster because
we're adding more and more nitrogen to
grow our food that makes its way into
soils and it makes its way into the
ocean and these microbes are having to
process that nitrogen to keep waters
clean and in the process of doing that
they're producing more and more of these
greenhouse gases so we can detect the
impact of microbes but all the way up in
the stratosphere we can measure the
activity of microbes here on earth but
we're particularly interested in is
coral bleaching and what causes it and
so I think there's very likely a viral
component to that and so that's what we
were doing it down in Curacao we were
trying to isolate viruses that kill
coral and or at least the symbiotic in
coral and so we've got a bunch of
experiments going on right now to see in
fact if we can identify viral pathogens
that might be involved in coral
bleaching and that's a huge thing right
now in the Great Barrier Reef very large
percentage that reef right
now is completely bleached
[Music]
what happens on a coral reef normally is
that it does actually support mostly
macro life so big sharks big fish and
then of course the corals provides a
habitat in the structure that everything
is just like a forest for deer or
something about nature the thing that we
think is the most damaging is actually
the overfishing of the big fish and the
Sharks normally there's a certain amount
of photosynthesis going on you always
get a certain amount of sunlight which
means that you always get a certain
amount of sugar produced and that sugar
can either feed the big fish or concede
the microbes so if you remove the big
fish then you start feeding the microbes
and the microbes the more of them you
feed you get more of them but you also
get different types of microbes and the
types of you get are the ones that you
don't want they're actually the ones
that go on to kill off the corals
themselves so there's a really tight
connection between either having a whole
bunch of sharks and big fish and there
is few microbes or removing those and
getting lots of microbes and killing off
the corals
the oceans are so understudied so what
we really need now is to basically
understand what the oceans look like now
if we want to have any hope of
understanding if they're changing so
they're very there's very little known
about microbes that live in the deep
ocean and so to be able to ask the
question if we're affecting the deep
ocean if climate change is impacting the
microbes in the ocean we can't answer
that question now and it's going to take
a lot of people and a lot of cooperation
to figure out if we can answer that
question to see if microbes in the ocean
especially the deep ocean are changing
as a result of the changes that we're
causing on the planet this kind of work
is really important you can imagine this
big machine working it's a big
complicated machine and we know that
we're doing things that are changing how
that machine works we don't know how the
machine works and so you don't really
know what the change is going to do
you're seeing at rattling some big
machine and it's changing and you don't
know what it's going to do so the first
order of business is to figure out how
it's supposed to be get the baseline and
then when change is happening you can
see it right now we don't have the
baseline we don't know what the oceans
supposed to have in it I mean change is
normal with evolution but we don't have
a healthy baseline to go from so we're
measuring change as best we can from a
moving baseline so there's a whole lot
of work that we need to get done really
quickly if we're going to start looking
at environmental change and how it's
affecting these ecosystems the world is
getting warmer the climate is going to
change and symbiosis react different so
what happens is organisms react to
changing temperatures that symbiosis
react in different ways to changing
environments including temperature and
so understanding what will happen as the
world changes as that as the ocean
changes in acidity as the world as the
temperature average temperatures warm
you have to understand how it's how
symbiosis work to understand what to
have any idea of what's going to happen
unfortunately for me I'm relatively
young and new in this field and a lot of
the worst changes have already happened
to the coral reef ecosystem zone
especially in the Caribbean there's been
really that ecosystem has really
fundamentally changed from what it was
so in a lot of cases were sort of
playing catch-up and trying to act kind
of as forensic scientists and figure out
what happened I'd also say a lot of the
changes that are happening to our oceans
aren't necessarily visible to us and by
the time we can see it it's kind of too
late so that's one reason that we're
hoping by looking at the chemistry of
the water and looking at what microbes
are in the water that might tell us
something about what's happening in the
ocean before it gets to a catastrophic
state that we can see with our eyes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you